. Remember that a membership at Join
Pakman Dotcom, always the best way
to support your favorite or least favorite
or second favorite or third favorite show.
Wherever we fall on the ranking sign
up at Join Pakman dot com coupon code
Fresh Start. Let's take some calls through
our Dischord channel Dischord server at
David Pakman Dotcom Discord. We're going
to go first to Joseph from Costa Rica.
We've never had a call from Costa Rica.
Joseph, you're on. What is on your mind today?
Hi, yeah, can you hear me? I can hear you.
OK, so I was actually going to ask if. Do you know
if there's any precedent of actually the right
now elected president of the U.S. of deposing
somebody in the Supreme Court or something like
that because of the election of Amy Barrett?
I don't know what you I don't understand the
question you're saying. Is there a president
who's who can depose a Supreme Court justice?
Yeah, like actually removing her or.
No, you'd have you'd have to go through
impeachment. You'd have to go through
impeachment of a Supreme Court justice.
Oh, so that's actually possible, you
see, if there's any possibility of
actually Joe Biden doing that?
No, not at all. Sadly, no.
I think it's much more likely if Joe Biden
wants to do something with the court,
he he would sooner expand the court, add justices.
Then he would get a and remember, the impeachment
process goes through the House and Senate. So
ultimately, it's not up to Joe Biden anyway.
OK, yeah, that's actually pretty bad. Well,
at least right now there's a little bit of hope.
Yes, right. Yeah, no, I think that that battle
has been lost, but there are other
things Joe Biden could do, huh?
Thank you.
David Joseph from Costa Rica. Thank you very much.
I appreciate that. We are taking calls through
discord at David Pakman dot com slash discord.